[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUILLAUME LAFORGE: Hi.
I'm Guillaume Laforge.
In this video, my colleague
Ray Tsang and myself
will teach you about Cloud
Functions for Java 11,
how to create a function, test
it locally, and deploy it.
In Cloud Functions
for Java 11, you
can create two types of
functions, HTTP and background
functions.
Let's create an HTTP function.
It just needs to implement
the HTTP function interface
and you can get the request
payload and the request object
and write the response to
the response writer object.
And that's it.
To run this function
locally, you
can use the function maven
plugin and run mvn functionrun.
And now the function
will respond on port 8080
on local host.
To deploy the function, you can
use the G Cloud command line.
Alternatively, you can also
use the function plugin
and it's deploy go.
Now I'll let Ray tell you
about background functions.
RAY TSANG: If you want to
respond to events from Cloud
resources like Cloud Storage,
Cloud PubSub, Firestore
and more, then you can
create a background function
to respond to
these Cloud events.
Simply implement the
background function interface,
inspect the event object,
and when you deploy,
specify the trigger that you
want to receive the Cloud
event from.
In addition to our
function framework,
you can also build functions
with your favorite frameworks.
Here we have an example
of a function written
using Micronaut, using
the Micronaut programming
model and the annotations.
And here we have an example
of a function written
using Spring Cloud Functions.
And the function is just
a Java function annotated
as a spring bean.
Last but not least, you can use
any alternative JVM languages,
like Kotlin, Groovy,
Scala, and more.
So check out our Cloud Functions
for Java 11 documentation
and give it a try today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]